it was a year ago it was what 15 months
ago I believe when Seth Wickersham of
ESPN came out with that expose on the
Patriots this was pretty much the
beginning of the end
is this the the is this the end of the
Patriots and of course we realized that
it wasn't you know their State of the
Union of what was happening with the
Patriots and turmoil and what was going
on Brady and Belichick and you know
there was just a mess behind the scenes
and then lo and behold they win the
Super Bowl Tom II current Patriots
insider NBC Sports Boston joining us
does it seem like it was 15 months ago
that that article came out on the SPN
well the funny thing is Dan that a lot
of it and I wrote the week flyer that
there was an end of the party feel to it
and guys were grabbing their coats and
had not a lot of it came to fruition but
what the Patriots are trying to do and
I'm they might be on their way to
successfully doing is rebooting and
creating kind of the Patriots 3.0
version of the dynasty because they
certainly were in the 2.0 and it was
waning so yeah I think I think the funny
thing is is there was nothing inaccurate
about that whether it be my reporting
excessive reporting or anyone's
reporting it's just that when push came
to shove they got through it and put the
football first also you're looking at
so are they reinventing themselves again
it feels like no team is reinvented
themselves as many times as the Patriots
and by that I mean are they a defensive
team are they an offensive team are they
neither they balanced what their power
they're a power football team if they're
turning themselves into a power football
team you see in the draft you see in the
offensive players they took you see in
their trend was going to a running style
offense much more balanced not run the
heavy not run orient it not run first
but much more physical the receiver they
take at the top of the draft it's kind
of like an incline Bolden aquila in-kwon
Bolden Dez Bryant you know body people
up type receiver and defensively they
have a great secondary so they want to
play you know I don't to get too far
into the X's and O's the press man get
up in your face smash people down so I
think it's fascinating to see the
direction they're going now
into the 2020
double-check make all the draft picks
ultimately but they do have very much a
collaborative way in which they put the
board together you know Belichick is
consistently appreciative of Monty
Austin fort who's the director of
college scouting and Nick Caesarea they
do all the work they set the boards
what's fascinating is they have such a
small staff especially this year because
they barely hired any coaches that it's
a collaborative effort between those
people it's not like Belichick gets all
the info tells everybody to screw and
says we're taking this guy I find it
amazing though that no information gets
out with the Patriots you telling me
yeah but I was told a long time ago and
not too long ago that the Patriots were
interested in Josh Rosen and it was even
told to me under like this veil of
secrecy you know you can't even say you
know sources close to or any of that
stuff and I didn't know if they could
have gotten Josh Rosen did they want him
more than you know the the guy that they
drafted Jared Stidham all right
and I'm not disputing your source yeah
but this is this goes to I mean you're
pretty smart you know some people I'm
sure the people you talk to also well
plug me in I've been doing this for a
while I talked to some people here I
heard the opposite yeah they just didn't
value him at that level so this goes to
the you know office you kid they screw
everybody up they're very opaque they're
very opaque so as a result I don't think
that they ever really wanted Josh Rosen
even though I made a hell of a lot of
sense you're not going to get a top 10
value if you're the New England Patriots
at the quarterback position anytime soon
so it made sense to me but Stidham
really when you look at it and you watch
his film you see why they are enticed
especially if he can sit there as an
apprentice my god he's going to jump off
the page during training camp as the guy
who delivers the best football that
includes the greatest quarterback to
play is he the European
he's gonna have every opportunity to
prove it he's gonna have every up
because I Tom Brady had it in him at the
age of 37 to 40 to beat back the Jimmy
Garoppolo challenge and he did it
successfully and screwed up the Patriots
entire plan I think that miss instance I
don't know if he's gonna have it in him
again not that he wouldn't have the
stomach for it but just that well not
that he wouldn't have a talent but yes
we might be you know what okay you're 22
I'm all set this kid can have it but
this Brady take him unders is he one of
those guys that can take you under his
wings and help you he can do either one
and he absolutely you know he wasn't
actively hiding Jimmy Garoppolo his
helmet but you know he he didn't really
go overboard to try and Shepherd him
into taking his job and I don't blame
him for that I mean he's built something
here he moved his family here he built a
palatial Brookline estate got his kids
going to school he's gonna help Jimmy
Garoppolo succeed him screw that but he
didn't actively try to undermine them I
think in students case I think he'll
probably follow the same approach a lot
of these guys whether it's Wes Welker
with Julian Edelman or any other NFL
address these guys say you know what
learn it from the coaches I'm not a
coach and then at some point they might
start to help give us some tips we're
talking to Tommy Kerr in the Patriots
insider NBC Sports Boston any chance
Gronk comes back I think people like us
and that includes people within the
Patriots organization and media are a
lot more hopeful and optimistic than
they ought to be you know and the things
that Gronk has said I encountered him on
the road just by happenstance a few
weeks ago he's happy as hell this is the
first time in 20 odd years he hasn't had
somebody up his posterior telling him
where to go where to be and to put his
body in harm's way
so we'll see how he feels
but I wouldn't say it the done deal I'm
not saying it's not going to happen but
I wouldn't say that it's a done deal
that people like myself felt it
might have been when he initially
stepped away where does the situation
between Robert Kraft and the NFL
stand on any discipline for him what I
found interesting was when Roger Goodell
said at the owners meetings when asked
about Kraft he said we're going to be
smart and fair about it which would be a
huge deviation from the norm when it
comes to discipline in the NFL so it
almost indicated that look we're not
going to rush to judgment on your Robert
if you have a plausible desire
explanation for what exactly would cause
you on a Saturday afternoon to stroll up
to a you know a strip mall spa and do
whatever as I I think that they're going
to try and be fair about it but that's
what's interesting to me is the way
you're going to continue to fight this
if your only issue is you don't want the
video out yeah they just take the plea
deal
everyone has long since gotten over it
now that the notion of human trafficking
at that location or in that
investigation has not been unearthed
just say look we got a little confused
as to what was going to happen in there
so I don't want the video out c'est la
vie but fighting to pretend that you're
not going to get suspended if this thing
gets somehow thrown out I think unless
he's got an assurance of that is
wrongheaded but I think the video still
gets out though Tom whether he does
yeah pleads or not I mean yeah so I mean
that's that's the thing you're exactly
right I'm almost kind of screwing the
pooch and explaining it even after it
goes through they have that Sunshine Law
whatever it is which everything every
bit of evidence is going to be unveiled
so part of me says Robert Kraft should
just say you know what if it's going to
get out here's a statement you might not
enjoy what you see it if you do I live
in Brookline against buy it anytime I
mean think about that just do exactly
what anybody who has headed off an
investigation in the past and as Mel
Bezos how did Jeff Bezos undermine the
National Enquirer
by saying exactly what they would find
so I mean there's there's a way to
circumvent this but do you think that
affects his role with this team this
upcoming season no I don't I thought it
might but if every indication I've got
and he hasn't deviated at all from the
normal Robert Kraft way of doing things
I mean he's hands-on you know I think
that at nearly 80 years old which is
bizarre he's not as sharp as he probably
was 20 years ago but that doesn't mean
I'm sharper than him I think he's still
a brilliant guy and is in control of a
lot of things and you know the way he
portrayed himself and his comportment at
the owners meetings showed that he's not
loosening his hand on the reins of some
of the NFL committee cities on nor is he
leaving himself vulnerable to people
saying you know what we're not going to
deal with this guy anymore so I think
that was an interesting outgrowth of
what we've seen in the last couple
months I'm going to visit with you
there's no controversy no drama up there
this is kind of weird I said it was
gonna be a drama-free offseason you're
joking right this I mean we got we have
a sex tape with the owner and we have a
Hall of Fame tight end that retired
might come back there's no drama you're
saying it's kind of low on the totem
pole for me you know being relative to I
guess yeah yeah I mean are you guys
gonna have a tight end this year with
the Patriots are you just gonna leave it
you're gonna go out there with like ten
guys just as a tribute to Gronk you guys
I just cover the team okay all right you
guys come on I don't know they did you
really Jacob Hollister yesterday is like
the only guy they had of them so Faria
Jenkins did you get a Super Bowl ring um
hey you know what I gotta go thank you
Tom Tom Curren for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on VR
or download the Dan Patrick show app